hello everyone and welcome to a really
nice game from the first ever online
olympiad uh for people with disabilities
organized by fiji
uh like the previous time we've uh we've
done this video
asked me to choose a game and decided my
favorites that
nominated for the gospel and brilliancy
prize and this is the game uh that i
have chosen now i didn't go through all
of the games because there were
400 players uh with reserves it was a 61
teams from 45 different countries
uh but rather fida sent me some 15 games
for me to choose from
and this is the one i chose but before
we check out the game uh it's a game
between
michael aigna and adriano albiani barata
just a short message from grandmaster
thomas luther
so let's check that out and then we're
gonna continue
with the game so here it is
hi everybody this is thomas luther
thanks antonio for having me in your
channel
two days ago the olympiad for people
with disabilities concluded
my congratulations to the winners the
the polish team
won gold and also to the russian team
the silver medalist
and ukraine the bronze medalist yeah
congratulations and of course
congratulations to all the players who
participated
i know having a disability
is never easy and by participation all
the players already
already overcame lots of their personal
problems it's a great success story for
me this olympiad
is a very personal issue you might know
that i'm a person with a disability and
20 years ago well i not only became
grand master i was the first
player with a disability who under
defeated top 100 list
since then i'm in organizing
and at this moment i'm sharing the
feeder commission
for the disabled in this
in this job i was part of organizing
this tournament the olympiad for
disabled
and it was a huge step forward into the
future
the chess olympiad itself is nearly a
hundred years old
later on the olympiads for women
and and for juniors were added so this
is
this is just another step to this great
event
that we now have the competition for
people with disabilities
to have a brilliant surprise is a great
idea
and thanks to the sponsors of this prize
and there were lots of interesting games
played in this event
lots of nice games not lots of nice
combinations and the choice wasn't easy
so my vote goes finally to to the game
of michael eichner
versus adriano barrata here
white had a very nice kingside attack
with a piece sacrifice and later a
beautiful checkmate
so okay congratulations to do michael
this is my vote
and thanks for everybody who helped
support
this event thank you so much
so uh there you have it uh thank you
thomas for that a wonderful message
i also went through all of the games and
i decided that this one
was was the game to show and uh here it
is here's the game
and we're gonna talk a little bit about
uh uh well
the olympiad in the uh thomas and some
other things after we check out the game
we're not gonna
uh do well too long on on every move but
we are going to cover the the most
important parts as usual
so agna opens with e4
sorry about that for example uh for some
reason
the board is not functioning i will have
to refresh it
there we go all right so e4 uh we have
uh
uh c5 the sicilian defenses on the board
and now knight to c3 so not going for
the main line
uh going for the for the close sicilian
uh we have knight to c6 and now
g3 preparing to fiance with the light
square bishop we have g6 uh and now
bishop to g2 black does the same bishop
g7
and d3 and here the this line is played
a lot in top tier games uh however uh
here d6 is the top idea however
a barata goes for e5 and it's also a
well-known move
uh just a bit of a sideline here we have
knight
to h3 uh developing the knight to h3
and this is probably with the idea of
controlling the g5 square
the knight can also be developed to e2
it will also support
the for example castles and f4 at some
point when you decide to do it
but knight h3 it's a bit of a bit of a
different move than than usual and uh
well
preparing bishop to g5 uh with knight
digita e7 black also develops prepares
the castle and
now f4 now as planned we have d6 and now
both players castle we have castles
and castles but castling for black here
was maybe
maybe a little bit dangerous because uh
well as you'll see in the game
white has something very devious planned
here h5 maybe
maybe stopping white's further expansion
is the way to go but okay
we have castles and now comes f5 by
white
so already it's a very unpleasant
position as of move 9
f6 is being threatened which would win
material so here black needs to
figure out how to deal with this so
black pushes f6
is this one of the positions where f6
will cost
some on the game it's hard to say but
here white continues with the g4
not worried about uh well making uh
uh moving the pawns in front of his own
king uh because uh
white will be able to use the g file a
lot more than black because here
for example if black decided to capture
uh white would of course play
king h1 bring the rooks into the game
bring the bishop into the game whereas
black would have some difficulties uh
uh well activating these knights the
bishop it's very hard to activate the
bishop so
uh it would be white who would benefit
most from opening up the g file so here
black decides to keep it closed the g5
and now comes knight to f2 uh you could
go for the immediate knight captures on
g5 but
uh white white uh waits a little bit for
this
because it doesn't seem like black has
all that much to do so white first
wants to get this pawn into into the
game and then white will
decide when he's gonna break through on
the king's side so rook b8 black plans
to start pushing the b
pawn and bishop to e3 now white
continues development we have b5 and now
queen to d2 we have h6 by black and now
h4 we're preparing to bust open the king
side
a6 and now comes knight to h3 and here
be b4 just pushing back that knight so
knight to e2
knight is coming to g3 and now knight to
d4 so that's a very active knight at
some point white will have to decide
whether to keep it there or just uh
trade one of the pieces for it so here
knight to g3
and knight e to c6 now uh it's very hard
to
get these knights into the game the
white spawn structure here is just uh
beautiful especially since black has a
light square bishop completely blocks
thin so black will also need to figure
out a way how to activate that bishop
so here although you could capture an h4
right away it looks uh looks a bit
dangerous giving white so much uh so
much space so
instead we have knight to e6 like we
said and rook to f2
white will now double rooks on the f
file we have bishop to d7 and now
rook a to f1 so the rooks are now nicely
doubled and here
bishop to e8 trying to activate this
bishop
any in any way possible here we have a
capture with h captures and g5 h
captures and now c3 getting rid of the
knight so uh deciding uh
not to give up any pieces for that
knight we have captures captures and now
knight to b5
and here uh before rushing in with any
any knight captures or bishop captures
and g5 ideas first pushing back the
knight even further
knight to c7 and now comes bishop to f3
here white wants to now occupy the h
file for the rook says this is now
uh aside from the b file the only open
file on the board so bishop to f7 by
black
and now bishop to d1
we have knight to a5 and now rook to h2
so
the rook is brought to the h file and
here we have queen to e7 and now
you can even pause the video here and
try to figure out what white played here
uh to try and make a breakthrough but i
i think you already
know now because we we kind of mentioned
it but you know you didn't know
at which point in the game uh white will
go go for it
so uh it's not really even uh even a
peace sacrifice because black's pieces
are
very much uh misplaced night knights not
really
uh being included in the game uh but
it's uh
it's a it's a weird opening uh so here
knight captures on g5 for those of you
who who were able to do it
congratulations uh and this is for those
of you who just want to enjoy the
show g captures in the now bishop
capture so grabbing those two pawns for
the piece
so like i said you can't really even
consider this a sacrifice
bishop to h6 and now bishop to h6 with
tempo as the rook is under attack and
now you're preparing g5
so rook f2 d8 and then now comes g5
the bishop has to move we have bishop to
h8 and now
g6 so this is now this is really now a
monster pawn chain
bishop back to e8 and now comes knights
to h5
and it was in this position on move 32
that adriano albiani barata resigned the
game
ended a a brilliant victory for um
for mikhail aigna uh as black really has
has no options here whatever you do
you're just getting crushed this wins a
piece you can even just continue pushing
i mean there's there's nothing for for
black to do here if you try something
like bishop to f6
uh you can just capture it captures
captures and bishop to g5 just wins
material and it's
uh it it's really uh
it it would be it would be a pointless
uh
it would be pointless just to even
continue playing this game
so after this uh uh knight stage five
idea black resigned and
uh what a victory for white so this is
the game uh both thomas and
myself uh nominate for the for the grasp
from brilliant surprise uh
let me know if you guys agree for that
and they even made a special trophy
at uh well uh uh
commemorated this brilliancy prize here
is the trophy so let's check that out as
well so this is the gus from
uh trophy uh you can see how how amazing
it is it's hard to say if it's a can't
really decide if it's a king or a queen
could be both uh could be neither but i
think it is one of them or maybe it's
both
uh it's hard to say but it's it really
is a nice trophy really
really a nice one especially enjoy the
cloak very very hairy
hairy pottery but yeah there you have it
and
also i would just like to share this
with you as well
a little message from uh from ground
master thomas luther
luther you've heard his message in the
beginning of the video
it is a way to develop self-esteem and
earn recognition so
talking about chess here it says grand
master thomas luther
is a three-time german champion 1993
2002 and 2006
who reached the top 100 in the world
ranking
thomas became a world-class figure in an
extremely competitive field despite the
added challenge of being bored
born with a physical disability learning
chess at another
at an early age was key for me to
succeed in life
the chess olympia for people with
disabilities will give a voice to
disadvantaged people and will also help
them to develop self-esteem and earn
recognition chess is the only
all-inclusive sport
explains uh thomas here in these events
there are people
uh who are facing challenges in life and
they will have the opportunity to meet
other people
facing similar chances so there is a lot
of communication and friendships develop
among the players the social aspects
are very important so there are
countless
reasons for you to place chess uh i i
can't think of a reason why not to play
chess even but uh you know
yeah the the reasons are countless and
uh here we have uh
some some some very nice reasons by by
thomas who is also
uh who also struggled or struggled with
some of these problems uh you know uh
growing up and advancing in chess as he
he did
break into the top top 100 chess players
in the world
uh so yeah uh i will also include a nice
article uh from the new york times about
michael agna if you want to check that
out it will be the first link in the
description below and also
congratulations to the winners
of the olympiad uh first place poland
second place russia and third place
ukraine
uh so yeah uh that's the game i i do
hope you guys enjoyed it let me know if
you uh
if you enjoyed the game um it's uh
uh there are other of course uh choices
online i've seen some other
some other player uh well youtubers and
twitch streamers
already announced their picks so you can
check that out as well and decide on
which one you you like the best uh but
yeah
uh that's uh the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank
a mystery person derek king giovanni
bella james hipps and
the pizza guy for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day